INTERVIEWER: War is a
devastating but real part
of life that affects millions
of people around the world.
We see the explosions
and troops on TV.
War leaves behind scarred
earth and communities
left to pick up the
pieces, trying to rebuild
the life they once knew.
And in some cases, using
the remnants of war to
do just that.
MARK WATSON: My
name is Mark Watson.
I'm a professional
photographer based
in Lyttelton, New Zealand.
This image was taken in the
southeast Asian country of Laos
in Khammouane Province.
INTERVIEWER: Mark was in
Laos during an epic bike
tour of Asia, starting in China
and riding 13,000 kilometers
to Indonesia, a trip
that lasted nine months.
MARK WATSON: Our route took us
through China, Laos, Vietnam,
Cambodia, Thailand,
Malaysia, and Indonesia.
We chose to keep our
trip to rural areas
mostly and in the
mountains and high country
as much as possible.
I find it fascinating to see how
people live in remote places.
INTERVIEWER: But it was
after entering Laos that Mark
discovered a new fascination.
MARK WATSON: I became
curious about this war scrap
everywhere, shrapnel,
bomb casings,
cylinders from cluster bombs,
and the long-range fuel
canisters.
During the years 1953 to
1975, a fierce civil war
was fought in Laos.
In many ways, this
conflict was overshadowed
by the war in
neighboring Vietnam
because both the American and
Vietnamese governments denied
their involvement in it.
From 1964 to 1973,
the US dropped
more than 2 million
tons of ordinance
on Laos during 580,000
bombing missions.
That's equal to a plane load
of bombs every 8 minutes,
24 hours a day, for 9 years.
This makes Laos the must heavily
bombed country per capita
in history.
INTERVIEWER: But it wasn't
the military history
Mark was interested in.
It was what happened after,
after the bombs ceased
and the troops returned home.
MARK WATSON: Up to a
third of the bombs dropped
did not explode, leaving
Laos contaminated
with vast quantities of
unexploded ordinance.
Scrap from such
widespread bombing
has been utilized in
people's homes and villages
for everything from house
foundations to planter boxes,
to buckets, cups, and cow bells.
This photo is of
local canoes that
been fabricated from war
scrap, because I recognize
them to have been made from
the discarded long-range fuel
tanks from American bombers.
INTERVIEWER: It's
a resourceful way
to deal with something that
caused so much tragedy,
but unfortunately, some
tragedies continue.
MARK WATSON: Over 20,000 people
have been killed or injured
by unexploded ordinance in
Laos since the bombing ceased.
To this day, these
munitions are still
scattered throughout
the countryside
and are frequently found and
often accidentally detonated.
This also created a
scrap metal industry,
which is now shrinking
but has been responsible
for many deaths as poor
villages recover and exchange
this dangerous
resource for money.
INTERVIEWER: Today
there are a number
of NGOs working to clear Laos
of these mines and bombs,
but at the current rate it
could take more than 100 years
to clear them all.
In the meantime,
people here are going
to have to continue to live
alongside these deadly relics
of war.
Photography undoubtedly
has the power
to change the way we
feel about many things,
including our ideas on war.
Check out this
episode next on how
photographers on the front
lines are doing just this.
SUBJECT: When people
started to photograph war,
these images helped bring the
realism and the horror of it
to the world, to people living
far away from the conflict.
INTERVIEWER: And as always,
don't forget to subscribe.
Thanks for watching.